with rise of the tmnt's movie coming to
netflix soon and the entire 2003 series
finally streaming in decent quality on a
legitimate albeit buggy and incompetent
service
i've been in a turtle's kind of mood
lately so let's indulge in some of the
shell-raising split-kicking
uncomfortable inter-species romancing
action with the recently released
shredders revenge and its much older
predecessor turtles and time you gotta
love how often shredder begins these
games by broadcasting his crimes in
broad daylight for all world to see i
like to think he'd have gotten away with
either of these statue of liberty heists
had he just waited until the super bowl
was on so there's a chance that the
turtles would be on a different channel
developed by tribute games founded by
some guys that worked on scott pilgrim
shredder's revenge is pretty obviously a
loving
tribute and sequel to tmnt turtles and
time now regarded as an arcade beat'em
up classic
not the 3d remake can't play anymore the
original though i did make a video on
that now lost piece of turtles media
because i have a working copy it's sort
of impossible to talk about shredders
revenge without talking about turtles
and time too so
i think if there's any place that i get
to review that game i might as well just
toss it in here too
but first a word from our sponsor you're
all probably waiting for the new tmnt
movies coming out soon like me
and the weight can be pretty grueling if
you don't have something to kill the
time why not pass the time by saving
hero wars from the dreadful archdemon a
game you can get now with the link in
the description you're gonna need a
fearsome fighting hero team of your own
for that task if you can't pick between
all these cool heroes i suggest celeste
should be a perfect fit for any team and
with your team built you can challenge
opponents online to test your skills in
hero wars you can claim rewards and
level up to prepare for the ultimate
battle because even the most deadly and
dangerous of bosses can be brought down
with the right team
join the game now and get a super chest
with five top heroes one of them is
secret as well as 600 emeralds and 30
000 gold the game is available on any
device just scan the qr code or tap the
link in the description to start playing
now how many heroes did you see in this
ad comment below if you think you
spotted all of them
now back to the
video turtles in time is based on the
much loved but hard to rewatch 80s
turtles cartoon ho ho i'm stepping on
some toes with that comment it's got
some interesting ideas for its combat
including moves that play with a
perspective in a clever way the turtles
try to get the shredder aka david
copperfield to return his absconded
superhero movie third act set piece and
he sends them on a trip through time
it's a wacky premise but it's par for
the course for ninja turtles
in most tmnt interpretations they do a
fair amount of time traveling or
dimension hopping adventures
and like all the time like every single
one i'm talking longer so i can show
more clips of how often it happens it
makes for some really creative stages to
go through history you remember history
class right
all the most important parts of history
are here
the dinosaur ages
uh the time when everyone was pirates
and uh cowboy times
that's all the important ones
oh and
the future it would have been too much
of a bummer to have the turtles fighting
ninjas with world war one trenches in
the background filling up with mustard
gas and soldiers with trench foot
tearing their flesh to get out of their
boots to climb away from the lung
burning chemicals in fact a lot of
historical time periods are pretty
depressing
uh they only went for the stuff that
could be a little fun
pirates are okay if you ignore some of
the edgier parts of them and just keep
your mind squarely focused on the word
swashbuckling then you go to the future
where everything is shiny and chrome and
impractical
that's the world i want to live in the
bosses are of course a few recurring
villains from the series but they also
had toca and razar because movie synergy
even though they weren't in the cartoon
back then
bebop and rocksteady nah these guys are
where it's at these two
ugly character designs with no
personality that appear for one movie
but eventually they were in the series
two years after this game came out
then shredder becomes
super shredder
because movie synergy
geez is this a marvel game then you lose
because it takes too many coins to beat
him at the arcade and money doesn't grow
on trees
it's a fun romp when you play with a
friend or well number three but it shows
its age for one i find that the controls
are sort of limited by only using two
buttons you can jump and you can punch
and all of your moves are sort of a
combination of mashing those two
but nothing more complex than that i
feel like the characters could all use a
little more variety in their move sets
because they all play pretty much the
same outside of one special attack
that's unique tortuga
given that it's a four player game home
console release was only two player
because snes and genesis only had two
controller ports i get why they don't
have any playable characters other than
the turtles themselves but having kc
splinter in april would be nice i'm
foreshadowing the enemies thankfully
have a nice bit of variety based on each
stage and various types of foot soldiers
so fighting them keeps you on your toes
without being totally unfair
they get their quarters from the bosses
because some of them have some pretty
cheap moves that can't be avoided the
only way to effectively beat them is to
trap them in a corner as a squad of four
and just spam as much damage as you can
ultimate alliance style
back in the old days two guys with the
right timing could curb stomp one of
these bosses in 30 seconds
turtle power means no more teeth for you
[ __ ] overall it's a fairly simple game
but you don't need complexity when the
fundamentals are so strong although
throwing complexity on those
fundamentals
this game stands the test of time as
just a really solid beat em up and a
really great attempt to bring the 80s
cartoons feel and look into a playable
setting it's all the excitement of an
average episode of the show with you
behind the controls and that's more than
you can save for most licensed game from
around this time trying to replicate the
feeling of other shows and movies being
that turtles and time is such a strong
foundation it's no wonder that this
game's spiritual successor soft reboot
kind of remake wutang album is such a
stellar follow-up okay this one i got a
download code for this one thanks thanks
to thanks to tribute games for the
download i appreciate that trailer's
revenge only came out this year and it's
already gotten that instant classic
feeling to it i just feel it in my ooze
irradiated phones people are going to be
referring back to this as the gold
standard for 2d beat em ups for a long
time
wait does this count as 2d if you can
move up and down too
surely yeah right like that's
um
the maps have a lot of depth now
so it's not really a side scroller uh is
this 2.5 d
how many d's are there here someone help
me count the d's these nuts this game is
everything to love about turtles and
time but far more polished and more
modern the combat is way more refined
allowing for far more complicated combos
and movement look you can even juggle
the same foot soldier forever he needs
to be dead for four hours by the time he
finally hits the ground that's what
master splinter taught us then drop a
grenade on
you can do dive kicks and did supers and
i mean all that was in the other game
but now it's like it's fancier shredder
wants revenge for
well just take your pick and then starts
the game by snatching lady liberty once
again
this time there's no time travel though
instead of various time periods you
spend the majority of this game
exploring different areas in new york
you know the old classics ranging from
streets to rooftops to the mall to zoos
to the skyline to the highways to the
technodrome these levels have a lot of
love and detail put in them with visual
gags every few feet and so many layers
of scenery to make them feel really
lived in and recognizable from each
other pretty much every level in this
game is distinct from all the rest and
that's no easy feat for modern game
designers just look at avengers
i know that's a low blow i'm sorry but
just
imagine a ninja turtles game with the
same kind of skin designs as the
avengers
that would be
just swell
the enemy variety in this game is even
better with dozens of different types of
foot soldiers that have to be fought in
different ways because they have
different weapons and different rules
but also some turtle mainstays like the
mauser robots and the triceratons plus
of course this game is a lot longer than
turtles in time with way more bosses
but it's cool seeing some of the
villains that appear in both and
comparing their sprites and movesets oh
my god they're even in this one too it's
toca and razar they're just gonna keep
putting them and stuff alright my
favorite boss in this game is probably
chrome dome because they once again
require you to do that throw ninjas at
the screen mechanic to stun him for a
few hits and that's that's really fun i
like it and would you look at that you
can play as april casey and splinter in
this game though you have to unlock
casey after the first playthrough and
some side quests side quests are really
simple and just come down to hunting for
special collectibles to hand off to some
of the supporting characters from the
cartoon
these quests let you unlock new moves
and buffs these and the challenges that
are unique to each level give some
really nice extra replayability which is
great because eventually games like this
start to tend to get a little tiring if
you're just mindlessly button mashing
for hours and hours
putting that extra layer on top of it
helps
somehow this one still hasn't lost its
charm yet and i just love playing it
with friends casually
given just how many characters locations
and ideas are here from the 80s series
this really feels like a perfect love
letter to that show
the gang's all here and this game's just
incredibly well put together and fun to
play with friends they have a six player
mode too
you imagine
having six people who like you enough to
come over to your house and play this
[ __ ] ninja turtle game with you
are you seriously playing this game
alone now i'm with my boys
[Applause]
oh wait the ps4 version is [ __ ] up and
can only play online or locally and not
a mix of the two so uh six player
feature does not work
[Applause]
uh is that being worked on it would be
cool if you could fix that
no okay
oh
anyway i still recommend this game even
though that's
depressing but yeah it's a good old
ninja turtles time and i i need to do
more ninja turtle videos i
give me your top 10 ninja turtles uh
video ideas so i can do more ninja
turtles videos
see you next time
you